Film Courage: When you’re attempting to
sell a screenplay, what are some of the deals
you will encounter?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter/Author: Well
there is the option agreement which is to
shop the material so they are not buying the
script.
There’s provisions for purchase of it but
it’s an option which means they have the
rights for let’s say three to six months
and they can have you do work on it or possibly
somebody else but they are optioning the rights
and you have to be…I’d say careful but
it’s going to take if off the market obviously
because they are paying you.
My first script sale (the spec) was optioned
three times in a row and I was doing all of
the rewrites which is good so they optioned
it for a number of…for quite a while (six
months at a time).
This allows them to find financing and that
may fall through so they don’t want to let
the project go and also have their imprint
on it you know what I mean?
So when it came time to execute the option
that means they have to purchase the script
and that was all in the contract and there
is also the outright purchase of the screenplay
and then you are usually given a chance to
rewrite it one draft with notes (with a polish)
and then if it doesn’t quite gel then there
is a provision for you to be let go and somebody
else can be brought on.
And then every time it’s a step deal so
there are steps.
Money to start - so when you read in the “Trades”
that the script sold for a million dollars,
they didn’t hand over a million dollars.
It’s only if the movie gets made does all
the money get paid.
It all sounds great but you get money up front
to start and let’s say you have to have
to do the outline or treatment you get money
for that to start and turn in so there’s
steps.
Then rewrites so the first draft if you’re
doing an assignment it’s the same thing,
money to write the first draft, money when
you turn it in, so it all goes by steps and
then there are provisions in each step for
how long it takes to read it and also for
how long you’re given to write it.
I mean after you write it there’s responsibilities
on both sides.
Your responsibility to write it and the producer’s
responsibility to read it in a timely fashion.
Meaning that they can’t go away for six
months and then suddenly get back to you.
Those are traditionally the type of working
contracts.
Question: What else should screenwriters know
about selling a screenplay?